this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
hello welcome to engineering in climate
change ee 292 H we have a fantastic
guest lecture today you'll enjoy very
much as you know the purpose of this
class is to empower you to help some of
the problems that stem from climate
change and we've had a pretty good tour
we're almost through the quarter now a
pretty good tour of many ways to do that
here we are at the electric vehicle
today booboo Dave Duff will be speaking
with us today and that will be really
really interesting we also have dick
Luthi coming up next well next time but
please keep in mind that's two weeks
from now we've got a little bit of
breathing room over Thanksgiving and
dick will be speaking to us about one of
the hugest climate issues there is water
so as always I could be reached la field
at stanford.edu please keep using
courseworks for your homework you've
been doing great on that I want to say
that the videos of the class as you
remember we went through taking the
videos down after professor will chew
his lecture for a while because he had
some confidential information in there I
believe we will have back to regular
access with will chew as lecture removed
from anybody being able to see it within
about a day so please if is there
anybody in this room who hasn't seen his
lecture who needs to okay and you can't
that's sorry okay I think it's going to
be safe to put everything back live
again after we take that off so last
call for will chew is lecture and then
for homework
the usual you've been sending in your
summaries it's great I have to apologize
that I have fallen behind I was out of
town actually three times in the last
weekend a day or so for my own
environmental project and so I'll read
and grade your summaries and questions
as soon as possible I should be
to catch up this week a lot of good
reading I will put this up on the
website so you can catch those readings
but there's a lot to read about water
and if you've got favorite references of
your own that you want to find go ahead
as always you don't have to read all of
this just read some and get a flavor of
what the issues are if you have
suggestions you know let us know I will
be posting all your suggestions again
when I catch up this week but some
general readings look through his site
see what his perspective on this is look
at professor David Kennedy site he's a
historian but it's really fascinating
stuff about water issues in the West
that are neat and then I find a lot of
things about the world water crisis that
focus on California which is near and
dear to here and also in India where
things are pretty dire already so take a
here are some suggested pointers just
take take a little world tour here and
get up to speed on on what's going on
it's it's pretty serious a lot of you
have kindly now suggested lecturers and
readings thank you and I'll be
tabulating those on the site to really
appreciate that you're making all of us
wiser so this is dick Luthi and he's
over in civil and environmental
engineering and is I'm really looking
forward to his lecture he's got a
tremendous background in this the
information opportunities here at
Stanford nearby are you know here are
the Stanford opportunities we know about
the AG you American Geophysical Union
annual meeting you can get one-day
passes I bet you can get a student rate
is up in San Francisco of course that's
probably right as you're coming to
finals but it's that's a huge meeting
and a great place to learn about a lot
of these issues and John just reminded
me before class that I had mentioned
that I would be giving a talk on my own
work soon that date has changed
we got moved and actually that's not a
bad thing I think originally it was
going to be tomorrow don't come try to
hear me talk tomorrow I won't be there I
will I will amend this
my Mac won't let me do that right now
but I will amend this slide to show you
what the real date is it's December 4th
it's the same day that I'll be talking
about my own work in this class so if
you find your appetite is whetted during
that lecture and you want to hear a
little different perspective or want to
hear it again then you can come to my
other talk that evening so it's gotten
moved to December 4th do not try to
attend to talk tomorrow and our guest
lecture without any further adieu we've
got Dave Duff senior mechanical engineer
at Tesla Motors he's got a terrific
background of many many cool engineering
projects including the Bellagio of
fountain and he's he's a graduate of
Stanford so a fellow colleague here of
the Student Life here to build cool
stuff is only part of what he does
embrace it Dave he really does and thank
you so much for being here
switches on now so I've been hanging
around Stanford campus since I was a kid
there may even still be bookcases in the
Dean of engineering office that I built
when I was in high school or something
when I was working for the one of the
one of the labs over there and but when
I went off to undergrad I went to Oregon
State University great program there and
mechanical engineering but one of the
things they didn't do very well at the
time I don't know if it's changed I hope
so was there was not a lot of hands-on
work in the shops and labs and that sort
of thing so I ended up having to get a
art minor just to get my hands dirty so
I I did a couple of years doing metal
smithing and jewelry work as as part of
my undergrad and then when I got out of
school I went off to to Lockheed which
if I had learned my lesson from
undergrad about getting my hands dirty I
wouldn't have gone there because I spent
the next 10 years doing simulation and
analysis work and giving presentations
at the Strategic Defense Command in
Huntsville Alabama and places like that
for a long time and I missed that so
much that I eventually abandoned that
career completely and came back to
Stanford to to make stuff because I
really enjoy making stuff so with that a
couple of years ago I was asked by the
science teacher at our grade school to
give a oh ok now I really need to pay
attention to what I'm doing here the
science teacher at our local grade
school asked me to give a little quick
talk at the science fair
so I did that
come on computer now we don't have an
aspect ratio problem oh all right hold
on we'll fix this
yeah I have an aspect ratio problem with
this mismatch between yeah maybe he's
gotten if he's got any thoughts I should
have done this beforehand obviously what
do you think well let's take care of it
what's the native for that one it's 1280
by 960 okay cross our fingers
how many of you actually are coming up
it's not happy
okay this is the I remember when I was
at Lockheed all those years that the
standard for presentations in the like
was view foils on a few foil projector
and the only thing that ever went wrong
was the bulbs always burned out and it's
still not coming up yeah please okay
let's try that is my other car which
does not classify as a fuel-efficient
vehicle now I actually have two oh yes
lovely mouse get it oh come on right
after this some talk I'm taking this
computer - I actually am - oh it's
coming back to the it wanting to default
onto the wrong screen yeah and now it's
not letting me even good grief
my favorite okay that's gone back to a
single display
well the chart also asked because
anybody who wanted to do a repo cash
deployment not
keeps showing up showing up great on my
screen so I can give this whole talk you
just won't get you just won't get to see
it oh and I got a cursor back that's a
sign it's doing it's it's so I spent
about ten years of Lockheed doing
ballistically ballistic defense stuff
and then came back to Stanford to do a
couple years in the graduate program in
a design program which was awesome I had
so much fun and when I left here I spent
a couple of years working for a company
down Los Angeles the wet design may have
heard of them they actually were founded
by another Stanford grad who did the
product design program mark fuller
because he really liked fountains and
water so I spent two years down there
working on aa genius yes a hand for that
man okay great and then after a couple
of years working on fountains
the one that was really memorable most
of my time there was spent working on
the Bellagio fountain which I'm sure
you've all seen in every television or
movie always seems to start if it
happens in Las Vegas starts with a shot
of that and then I went off to Xerox
PARC where I worked on robots oh well so
this photo was taken in the loft space
the old design loft space that is by the
mechanical engineering shops when I was
working on a light sculpture back in the
mid-90s and one of my projects for my
graduate actually this was more like
avoidance of working on my projects I
was supposed to be working on I made an
ice cream maker and this is a couple of
projects that I did as part of that
master's thesis work on Cup
I just did an exploration to a bunch of
different cups this is this is hand
raised silver and an elf you've any of
you ever seen this kind of work before
you start with flat sheet metal and you
start hammering on it and eventually you
raise up this form which can then be
this case soldered to a lost wax cast
stem and polished and all that sort of
thing and then these were I was really
proud of these especially recently these
are sort of stemless stemware which I've
noticed over the last couple of years
have actually been in stores I can say
that I actually built some back in 1995
I didn't make any money off that dough
so this is not this was the tea set I
did when I was in undergrad when I was
trying to get my hands dirty and
avoiding my mechanical engineering
homework
this was the Bellagio fountain when it
was when there was no water in the lake
so this lake is about ten or twelve
acres this would be sort of the opposite
of the environmental project because
this thing's consumes massive amounts of
energy right it's got three megawatts of
light fixtures in it and it spends all
of its time pumping water into an arid
environment right so maybe not the most
environmentally conscientious thing to
be working on it's very cool it mean
it's an awesome display but when you
start thinking about the stuff
underneath it you just gotta shake your
head the other project I work on after I
when I was at school was this robotics
project that was also a great fun and
when I got out of grad school and got
done with working at the fountain
company I went off to work at Xerox
proud Xerox PARC where we were working
on these modular self reconfiguring
robots these were these were a blast
very very cool
and interesting projects lots of
opportunities in that space and robotics
for for our future the one that comes to
mind today just because of my
involvement with Tesla is the
self-driving automobiles the impact that
will have on on our lives and our
environment in time will be I think will
be really dramatic not just for the for
the lives saved but also there's great
opportunities for increases in
efficiency and that sort of thing you
know imagine you're going to Grand
Canyon for the for your weekend or
you're over your week off or something
like that and you could just sort of
crawl into the back of your car and
snuggle into your pillow and sleeping
bag and tell it to get there around 8 o
clock in the morning and stop for coffee
when we get there please and you only
have to drive 25 miles an hour which is
the maximum efficiency speed so you can
save a lot of energy on the way so this
is sort of the work that I did before I
started at Tesla these robots these
actually they actually did stuff each
one of these little robot modules were
the same so they could all sort of not
each do very much but you put them
together in different configurations and
they can do interesting things oh and
this one I think this never works for me
so if it would have worked today I would
have really been stunned
see here well now my other folder got
shut off so courtesy of our computer
issues I'll work with my
never had those days where you worked
out way too hard the day before and then
you went out drinking late and then you
had to get up early the next morning
this guy it's a slow process but the
beauty of robots is that nobody has to
watch right we watch them because
they're interesting to watch but for the
most part they can just do their own
thing and take as long as they need to
because eventually the job will get done
those were those were a blast all right
so that's where I've been
let's talk about where I am
so this is actually my favorite slide in
the whole presentation it's not mine of
course Lawrence Livermore has been
cranking these out I hope you've seen
these because this slide before actually
because it's one that has so much I mean
Edward Tufte would love this slide right
it just this has so much information on
it and tells all kinds of different
stories in it one of the stories it
tells is what we do with two for
transportation how do we get from place
to place what do we use to get there
there's really only one thing we use
petroleum with fuels that's it there's a
little bit of you know some other stuff
biodiesel and natural gas and biomass
but for the most part it's all petroleum
and in fact it's very hard to do
anything but right fuels are just such
an efficient carrier of energy that is
very difficult to do anything else in
the transportation sector except use
some sort of fuel the other thing that's
the other story in this chart is about
how efficient these processes are right
so you look at the back side of this now
they've just made an assumption down
here about the efficiencies of various
processes so there probably ought to be
error bars around all these things
this chart assumes that the fuel use in
transportation is 25 percent efficient I
think that's sounds like a good number
every time I've gone out and looked
those are the kinds of numbers you see
it's hard to do better than that because
there are so many constraints on an
engine in a car right it has to fit into
a certain volume and has to fit into a
certain weight it has to fit into a
certain cost in order for it to work as
a as a prime mover for a vehicle that
you know efficiency is only one piece of
that total puzzle right if you look up
at the top
though in the electricity generation
there's a couple things you see one is
that there's any number of fuels will
work for that sector you can generate
electricity with almost anything and the
processes for generating electricity
from a fuel for instance are inherently
more efficient why because that's really
the only thing they have to focus on
aside from I mean obviously there's
emissions and all that sort of thing but
they don't have weight constraints they
don't have to lug these things around
the cost constraints are much looser
just because you've got a power plant
that's gonna sit there for potentially
decades cranking out energy and since
the primary cost of goods sold to a
power plant is the fuel that fuels it
you want to use as little of it as
possible so there's a huge incentive for
them to make that process as efficient
so if you can divert some of this
electricity down here and your
transportation you've accomplished a
couple of things one is you've reduced
your dependence on this one particular
class of fuels and you put yourself in a
space where you can do something more
efficient because you can separate the
operation of that vehicle from the
efficiency of the power generation
you're using to drive it so but there
are course challenges but before we get
to those talk a little bit more of this
so start with a gallon and a half of
gasoline why gal and a half because
that's roughly equivalent of 56 kilowatt
hours which is the amount of power and a
Tesla Roadster the battery pack which
right off the bat tells you a whole
nother story right $5 gas can was a
little bit of gas in it weighs this much
56 kilowatt hour battery pack that's you
know really big and costs tens of
thousands of dollars well there's
clearly some work to be done there but
this thing of course is used over and
over know
again and the efficiency of the process
in the electric vehicle is very high
conversion from battery through drive
electronics into motor out to wheels
is in this kind of 80 percent class
whereas for a gallon of gasoline most of
it goes out of the tailpipe the rest of
it goes to your wheels so just looking
at the sort of carbon footprint and and
dependency on petroleum fuels even the
most efficient vehicles you know in this
class are are using obviously using oil
using gasoline their emissions are
generally higher partially now this is
actually maybe the plus side of
expensive battery packs if battery packs
were cheap you wouldn't necessarily care
how big or efficient the car was in
terms of how much energy it takes to
push it through space but because
battery packs are expensive there's
actually a really strong motivation to
make them as small as possible which
pushes you to reduce the drag reduce the
weight make your car as efficient as it
possibly can be so that by the time you
do put that expensive battery pack in it
it can be as small as possible so here
are some comparisons of right so we've
been talked about sort of how efficient
the car is from taking power in the
battery to the wheels well okay but that
doesn't really tell the whole story of
getting that fuel to the power station
through the power station through your
electric transmission lines into your
car when you take it all together and
just do what they call the well
two-wheel energy calculation which I
presume a lot of you have seen before
something like the the Roadster
and actually really any all luck
vehicle is going to fall fall over it in
this category maybe not as great as the
roadster is but they're going to be over
there just because of the efficiency of
getting power from a power station as
opposed to generating it yourself in
your car and the drive to make the
electric vehicles as kind of efficient
as they can be for the for the payload
they've got to carry to keep cost down
so where are those costs coming from
well right now they they come from two
categories and those both of which have
huge opportunities to change the biggest
contributor is the actual cell itself
turns out and I don't really understand
the whole story but I'm guessing that
the all the laptops in our laps and on
our desks here have driven the
development of this particular cell this
lithium ion 18 650 is 18 millimeters in
diameter 65 millimeters long it's a
single cell that gives 3.7 volts or
whatever it is nominal and anywhere from
you know a few watt hours maybe up to as
many as 10 10 watt hours or something
like that they are for your money the
best deal in town except for lead acid
but I think the everybody right there is
not a single car out there except if you
go to a sort of obscure
build-it-yourself site that uses lead
acid battery packs for for vehicles the
only vehicles around that use those are
forklifts and they use them because they
needed ballast weight anyway so putting
a thousand pounds of battery on the back
of this thing just to hold it down is a
good thing and they don't they
also for the dollar they deliver a lot
of power but lithium-ion cells are the
next best thing
or actually well they're certainly the
best thing in terms of for vehicle use
the other the other big cost of course
to a battery pack is all the ancillary
stuff so when you take a bunch of these
cells and put them together lithium-ion
cells they need to be monitored you'll
want to make sure they're balanced you
know you take a stack of cells our
battery packs in the Model S for
instance is close to 400 volts it has
almost a hundred hundred bricks we call
them in series to stack up to give you
that 400 volts you want to make sure
that none of those little bricks get out
of whack that for some reason if there's
some maybe one of the cells has got a
little bit of a short-circuit in it or
something like that in it slowly
draining off the power in that one
little brick for those all those little
cells in parallel got to monitor the
voltage on that each one of those bricks
so you've got 100 bricks well then
you're going to need a hundred voltage
sensors keeping track of all that stuff
these things are sensitive to
temperature we've all heard stories
about them even in laptops but in other
places as well going into thermal
runaway so you want to monitor their
temperature you want to watch them even
you're right you're recharged double
hand tools have you know three leads on
every battery pack two for the actual
charging and a third one two for the
little temperature sensor that's in
there to monitor their temperature so
there's there's lots of management that
happens so inside you know inside a
roadster battery pack or a Tesla battery
pack there's a what they call a battle
battle battle battery management system
board one board that kind of takes
responsibility for the whole pack and
then there's another board for every one
of these modules and it has all the
little temperature and voltage sensing
lines going out and actually that
architecture is not unique to Tesla
most everybody who's building these days
it's great you can see lots of people
who you know cut open battery packs and
look what's inside and post videos on
YouTube and so you can go look at and
see how everybody else has solved this
problem and they're all sort of solving
it in the same ways they have a BMS
board to take care of the whole thing
and then these little VM bees that that
monitor individual modules people use
different approaches for cooling some of
them are some of the packs are very low
density and they blow air through them
to keep the temperature down we use
liquid cooling circulate a coolant
basically like the fluid in your
radiator through the pack to keep them
cool organ I shouldn't say nut just keep
them cool to maintain their temperature
there's cases where we actually heat
them up because they have a preferred
temperature operating range if you live
in Minnesota or Alaska and leave your
car out overnight it's actually more
efficient to waste some of the energy in
the battery pack to heat the whole thing
up so that you can use the heated pack
up for driving and there's you know
there's news it seems like every week
about another new battery technology and
how their people are moving forward in
this there's tons of room for growth in
this area there's also tons of room for
growth in this space and the enclosures
and the management systems for all that
a lot of lots of work to be done
some examples of cells that are out
there we've measured you know if there's
somebody out there making an 18-6 50
we've put it on our testers and and run
it to see where it falls in terms of
energy density and you can see they're
you know they're averaging about 200
watt hours per kilogram so what does
that mean in terms of a pack so when you
take packs and this is I don't know if
this is even a real number I mean we
talked about this number people
sometimes talk about these numbers and
compare but but in reality if there was
a
kind of competition around pack power
energy density then it would stop
mattering because people would
arbitrarily move things in and out of
the packs because you can do that it's
mostly its structure its electronics its
cooling system it's dead space but these
packs all run in this you know so you've
gone from a a cell at 200 watt hours per
kilogram to a pack which is something
you know order of half that the Model S
is is in that sort of 140 class so it's
high partially it's high because it's
large right the bigger you get the less
the overhead is for a given size so the
Model S is a big 85 kilowatt hour pack
so it has a higher density than a lot of
these smaller ones do okay so kind of
all this work right figured out that you
could build an electric car it's gonna
do all the stuff but you got to sell it
on the market what's it gonna cost so if
you start with you know one of these
cars and then you make some admittedly
gross assumptions right this is back in
the envelopes a lot of stuff
you say well lights guess that maybe 60%
of the purchase price of the car is
everything but all the stuff I would
take out if I was going to convert it
over and then I'm going to put back this
other stuff of which the battery pack is
by far the biggest component let's
assume that it's $600 per kilowatt hour
now you take a car take one of your cars
the compact the sedan your sports car
that is a space price of one of these
numbers assume that your car can go for
miles for every kilowatt hour you're
paying 600 bucks per kilowatt hour
battery pack that's 150 month 150
dollars on your purchase price for every
mile that you can
that car and then you can see really
obviously why the Nissan Leaf for
instance has a short range right you
would not take a $15,000 car and put in
a $50,000 battery pack nobody would buy
it right it's kind of like buying a one
hundred million dollar house that's on a
hundred dollar piece of property you
just you know something something wrong
about that equation and so as you move
up and the asunder you understand then
the motivation for Tesla getting started
at this really high end because at the
time they started they probably couldn't
have even produced a battery pack for
this cost much less made any money
selling a small number of vehicles for
twenty thousand dollars P so they
started way down here you know in a
hundred thousand dollar range but it
also shows you that what happens over
time is well if the more you can drop
that cost the more those battery packs
and electric vehicles make sense at a
for for more common less expensive
vehicles so here's some you know some
examples so if you start at four hundred
and fifty dollars per kilowatt hour a
battery pack well then your battery pack
is just going to cost a lot and in fact
this number is close to what the Model S
I think if you go online and look at the
Model S battery or go online at the MA
Tesla website they actually show you the
purchase price of the car with either
that 85 kilowatt hour or the 60 kilowatt
hour or the 40 kilowatt hour battery
pack and it's like a twenty thousand
dollar difference for 45 kilowatt hours
of power which is not that number but
it's something in that I'm getting my
numbers mixed up but I believe this
number is close to what the Model S is
and this is similar to what the Model S
range is about for
miles per kilowatt-hour so if she buy
the one that has 300 mile range you're
probably spending you know close to
$35,000 on the battery pack but as you
develop cars as you develop better
technology sorry for the batteries and
bring this cost down to 300 or 150 then
all of a sudden these numbers start
coming way down very quickly and they
make a huge difference to the purchase
price of the vehicle and make make those
make those cars a reality so the folks
who founded Tesla did all that and
decided to start a car company and this
was their first mule I don't even I was
trying to even look up what this vehicle
was I'm not even sure what it is but
it's it's what I'm sure they'd glad they
didn't go to market with that yeah it's
the load the the one that they actually
used for the Roadster is very similar to
the Lotus Elise doesn't look a lot like
any sort of looks like this but oh wait
oh that's interesting thought maybe
that's where they got that anyway that
one had some great properties too so
they built their first mule they got
into the business they had I think you
know the company was founded almost on
this decision what what sell right and
if you think about if you're gonna found
a company or start something big the
first thing you got to do is that
fundamental back at the envelope
question answer that fundamental
question on the back of the envelope
around the you know around a beer with
your buddies is does this make sense and
what would you use to make it all happen
and this is the crux of that right
selecting the battery is sort of the
first thing that you got to do because
you're gonna bet the whole come
bunny on that technology who's our old
building in st. Carlos making stuff you
know hooker by crook
you know coffee on the top of the stove
and melting who knows what in the bottom
epoxy potting or something like that the
first team of that mule
and then they kind of got you know
demonstrated they could do it figured
out how it was gonna be what it was
going to look like and then they got
seriously into the the design of the
roadster oh so this does address some
important things though
so battery packs are expensive so you're
really incentivized to keep that vehicle
lightweight and aerodynamic so some of
the two ways that you do that right off
the bat are you do an aluminum chassis
and a carbon fiber body the Model S is
all aluminum it's an aluminum body with
some aluminum substructure under
undercarriage and that's sort of
fundamental to that's one of the ways in
which electrics tend to be different
there's a lot of impetus to make
internal combustion engine vehicles
lightweight as well but the lever just
isn't as strong right it's not pushing
as hard to bring those things down has
this big battery pack right behind the
seats power electronics module and then
the motor and drivetrain in the back
I've driven these a few times I once we
were trying to put some high vibration
kind of miles on one that we had made
some changes to and so a bunch of us
were driving this one car every day
twice a day somebody was making a trip
from from Palo Alto to Boulder Creek by
going up Page Mill Skyline highway nine
to China grade road which is if you've
ever driven on it
is this sort of one and a half lane road
full of potholes and it's just nasty it
was
I almost got carsick and I was driving
and it just the whole cart was rattling
the entire time but it survives a trip
just fine and boy it just corners like a
dream and when you decide you want to
pass somebody you think about it and
then then you wondered where they went
Wow
oh that's those lights in the rear view
mirror very fast so in 2006 they
unveiled the Roadster in Santa Monica
big excitement there I've got some stars
to show up and I think it's a lot
prettier than the first mule they built
it's very fast
not a huge top speed and I think that's
really because it's it's only got one
speed there's no gearbox right you got a
ton of torque when you put your foot
down but but then the motor just
basically tops out it does it will do
240 miles on a charge which is which at
the time was and still today really is
is a pretty high bar there's not a lot
other vehicles doing that I think the
Model S maybe the only one and if you
ever you ever get a chance to look this
up on Wikipedia because you'll probably
be out there buying cars at some time
and you'll want to understand what the
heck mpge actually means and you have to
look it up to understand it because if I
tried to explain it I'm sure I would get
it wrong but basically it's it's telling
you how far you could go on the
equivalent of the equivalent energy in a
gallon of gas so if a normal car would
go 30 miles on a on a gallon of gas if
it were an electric vehicle it would
probably have about four times
that just because the gas engine is
about one-quarter of the efficiency of
taking power off battery and but you
sort of have to look at the details to
understand that zero mission zero gas
obviously so he started delivering in
2008 I heard this story that when they
started and it's much like it is today
at the Fremont factory the realities of
actually building cars right so if you
build a car and it's got five or 10,000
parts in it every one of those parts has
a purpose right otherwise it wouldn't be
there which means that you can't ship it
unless every one of those parts is in
there we saw this you know last year
right with with the earthquake and stuff
and in Japan right the company on the
planet that makes dorians latches for
everybody went down and every car
company in the world basically came to a
stop for a few weeks because nobody had
any door latches there's only one
company that makes them and and they
were out of commission same thing
happens to us not door latches but you
know any number of things anytime
something is not working it means that
cars start building up in the shop or in
the parking lot or wherever until that
thing gets resolved and then they can
fix them and send them out the door and
in the very beginning I there was a
story about you know you on must coming
into the factory and seeing 30 cars
parked inside not shipping to customers
and this was the first batch that was
going out and tearing his hair out and
telling everybody to get to work and
figure out what the heck's going wrong
and get these things out the door it
just takes a lot of work to build a car
there was just too many parts
well time frame that the Roadster
started shipping because it was getting
a lot of press and a lot of attention
Tesla started getting contracts to do
powertrain parts for other companies
so Mercedes was one of them and so they
started building the electric
you don't know whether it's just the
battery pack or whether there's
something more in there I'm not familiar
with very familiar with that program but
at least the battery pack in the in
smart Evie is his Tesla part 2009 they
unveiled the Model S that's when I
started in February 2009 so the first
thing I started on was and I work and
that worked in the battery pack
organizations so the first thing I
started working on was the battery pack
for the Model S we got this do a loan
guarantee we got investment from de mer
we got a contract with them for four
batteries for the a class know if you've
seen those around their cute little cars
2010 this was a big deal they've been
struggling with where to build the Model
S for a long time they had a couple of
different possibilities and then with
the relationship with Toyota happened
now it turned out that the president of
Toyota was not a fan of electric cars he
had made a statement like within a year
of this relationship saying Toyota is
never going to build an all-electric cuz
this is a dumb idea and then apparently
either we took a car to Japan or he came
over and was in town or something I
suspect somebody flew a car to Japan and
took him for a drive in the Roadster and
he got out of the car was like smiling
ear-to-ear and I was like okay where do
we start
it was really an eye-opening experience
and in fact after this investment
happened the Fremont factory was owned
by Toyota at that time GM Toyota had
owned it coned it and then GM had
abandoned Toyota had it so we we picked
it up for a song by by Bay Area property
price standards and then started working
on the rav4
there's a we've got this great I'm
shopping at the Deer Creek facilities
nearby here and big big open floor and
it always just seems to have this random
assortment of vehicles in it that have
either been built from scratch or
converted to electric and there have
been a lot of these rad floors around
which has been great they're very cool
in fact I've heard that of all Toyota's
cars not quite sure if this is right
it's either it's either first or second
but this is the fastest car that Toyota
has in terms of acceleration of all
their vehicles I don't think so
so last year finished the Roadster
production so that's done and and
started building the beta fleet so we've
done several iterations of cars right
like anything you're going to prototype
test the heck out of it refine the
design build another one except when you
build a car it just takes a whole lot
more effort to build a prototype than
and I ever would have imagined you know
you think about stamping a body panel
like big sheet metal panels how are you
going to build a prototype one of those
and yet they do there are companies in
of course in the Detroit area that
specialize in doing this kind of stuff
and just as an aside that particular
technology is they take this there's
some alloy of zinc and tin and aluminum
or something I it's called Curt site and
it's a fairly low melting temperature
very kind of brittle and stiff but
because it's such a low melting
temperature it's easy to recover so they
pour out and has very low shrink rate so
they can pour huge blocks this stuff
machine a shape into it stamp out a few
hundred body panels and then
melt it down and all the shavings that
went with it and start over again so you
actually can stamp out these big pieces
of stuff this Factory I'm always stunned
when I look because I have to figure out
how to get there sometimes and where I'm
going it's enormous
this picture doesn't do it justice
because this line of stuff on the right
hand side those are the train tracks it
was like 14 or a dozen parallel tracks
over here it's got almost the same
amount of train tracks as San Francisco
does coming dude it feels like it's a
huge facility inside this five million
square feet of space and when it was
first available to us and we were you
know kind of wandering around exploring
it felt like a movie set for some
post-apocalyptic disaster movie I mean
was just this horrible scary place you
ride your bicycle around with your
flashlight hoping you didn't fall into a
any number and he wanted the number of
giant open pits you know where there's
some giant stamping press had been that
they removed and so these are all these
little things down here are all semi
tractor-trailers and parking lots full
of cars and but a lot of production gets
all the assembly gets done here a lot of
production gets done here all the
stamping presses for bodies lots of
injection molded for big parts like
bumpers right it's just one big plastic
piece for a bumper skin it's happening
in here so here's some of the here's one
of the presses I think this is the one
you know this press can stamp out a
piece of sheet metal that's 20 feet long
or 15 feet long or something like that
and I think they bought this in Detroit
from somebody who didn't need it anymore
and they shipped it out it's like a
hundred train car loads of stuff you
know I don't know how many empty million
pounds of of material but there they
just bang parts out it's really amazing
to watch
here's this is door these are doors door
panels you can see the cutout for the
door handle a couple years ago none of
this existed this all new and it's it's
just amazing boggles my mind to watch
all these robots moving around doing all
this stuff that's great
I haven't been watching my time well
good perfect anyway it's all very cool
to watch it's great to see people are
excited working on these because they
really feel like they're part of
something that's very new there's some
definitely some new technologies I mean
there's lots of new technology in the
car that are just sort of car related
stuff but some of the challenges
manufacturing a car in aluminium it's
just a very different mindset than
designing a car out of steel forms
different there's different things you
can do with it you're going to extrude
aluminium you can't really do that with
steel you can easy to cast aluminium so
it changes changes what the parts end up
looking like how's this you know similar
structure in the rear end of the to the
Roadster the power electronics now the
power electronics are sort of a
cylindrical module that connects to the
battery packs they all go together and
then the battery pack sits down flat
underneath the rest of the car the parts
I designed or or the the plug or the
socket really on the back of the battery
pack and the plug that's in the car that
connects the two so on every time they
put a battery pack into the car I cross
my fingers and cringe
it's occasionally goes badly and when it
does people get really upset because
they're sort of towards the end right
and now it's my fault that the
production has stopped it's very very
disconcerting
beautiful card I actually haven't
written in the and a finished one the
only one I ever wrote in I think it it
had a windshield but I don't think it
had side windows or much of the interior
in it when I wrote in it it actually it
got motor trends Car of the Year
yesterday and it got automobile
magazines Car of the Year a couple weeks
ago and I think they've all sets were
the same thing that the body is yeah
it's nice is sort of what you'd expect
out of a high-end luxury sedan but it's
really when you start driving the thing
that you just get kind of wowed by the
the feel of it so if any of you are car
buffs it's funny I didn't appreciate it
when I went to work at Tesla but most of
the people there are sort of car buffs
in some way or another they may not
really it's not like every car in the
parking lot is some wacky thing but
there's a lot of them and then a lot of
people who are they're just they just
really like cars and so they you know
everybody loves getting in getting an
opportunity to drive one of these really
fun there's a test track at the new me
facility so you can actually go around
this with a high banked corners and all
that stuff which is very cool well scary
the first time you go around but and so
seats 5 in the kind of normal two and
three and then in the back and the under
the hatch in the back there's actually
these two little car seats for small
people and you can order it with either
the 162 30 or 300 mile driving range
it's expensive yes you guessed that for
all the reasons that I talked about in
the beginning and that's really where
the opportunities are for the future you
know the goal of this company was to to
really make the point and drive it home
hard that an electric car could be a
real car that
people would enjoy driving right and the
Roadster convinced a lot of people that
that was the case even in you know even
presidents of car companies that that
was the real deal so the next step is to
move move down the chain to something a
little bit more common still it's a
high-end luxury car but after that will
come the next one in the next one and
and hopefully this will start you know
start the avalanche where all the other
companies will get involved I've heard
Elon say you know he's not out there to
beat everybody he's happy to beat
everybody but what he wants is not for
us to be the only game in town for
electrics but really for this just to be
the starting point for for electrics
we've recently unveiled the Model X and
we're working on the Mercedes b-class so
Mercedes is going gung-ho on the stuff
Toyota is doing it as well and this we
have this new supercharger network which
is one of the questions I think somebody
submitted here's the B Class Model X
looks a lot like the Model S except
taller so a sort of SUV ish these what
do we call these they're they're not
that we don't call them gold wings
though they had another name for him
it's like the hawk wing or I'm getting
it wrong I can't remember because I
haven't seen one of these actually since
the unveiling but these are actually not
the front doors that do this is it's the
rear doors that do that the front doors
are conventional so the kids in the
backseat are the ones who get the really
cool unique experience anyway Falcon
thank you I knew there was this
supercharger network was just unveiled
we're starting with
facilities in California so these little
circles are your you know oh what range
is that I should be able to guess that
from the scale of the map must be a
couple hundred miles so California will
be well covered and what you get with
the supercharger is to say oh yeah 150
miles of range in 30 minutes so one of
the advantages of these lithium-ion
cells especially compared to like wet
acid or or anything really anything else
is that you can charge them quickly you
can push them hard and as long as you
watch their temperature and stuff you
really can put a lot into them you can't
take them all the way up to full charge
right because at the end if you look at
the charging profile for these cells and
I think almost all batteries are this
way the closer you get to a hundred
percent full the more you have to sort
of taper often and slow down so start in
California and then you know cover the
whole country eventually somebody will
be I don't know who I I heard somebody
had already done the coast-to-coast
drive in their model ass since they
bought it somehow I don't know how they
you know where they plugged in to do
that but they did it and when the
supercharger network gets really
completed you'll be able to do that
faster Joe so that's one of the ways
that that and these this kind of the
super charging thing is I would guess
this is something that's sort of here to
stay right if you're gonna put 80
hundred two hundred kilowatt hours into
a car that's a boatload of energy so
even if so even if the battery
technology is actually the more the
battery technology gets better means the
faster you'll be able to charge it
and the more capacity it will have so
these kind of super charging things
where you need to be able to dump a lot
of energy into them quickly is only
going to increase you're never going to
be able to do this I I can't imagine
you'd ever be able to do this at home
right I mean you think about how much
power you put into your tank at a gas
station it's like a megawatt you know
it's if you're sitting there pouring gas
in but it's like a megawatt going in
there at that rate it's just it's a huge
amount of energy that's going to you yes
sir oh so there is a company right
across the street from us better place
that had talked about doing that and I
gotta say that this is my personal bias
no way and the reason I say that is not
because it's not possible it's because
it's not I say it because I don't
personally believe that it's practical
that getting a bunch of car companies
actually getting a bunch of any
companies to agree to a standard form
for a battery pack such that you could
remove and replace it quickly just
sounds to me like I can't even imagine
trying to organize that you know having
that first meeting about hey let's do it
this way I want to do it my way this is
going to be beta times VHS times
three-quarter inch you know it just
seems to me like a very difficult
problem you've come up with a form
factor that people could sort of kind of
all go with like maybe something smaller
than the full battery pack like a like a
module where some cars might use - some
might use six whatever and that they
were somehow and then attached to the
car in a way that you could really get
them on and off easily there might there
might be a way to make that happen but I
I just
across its waddles hey yes even Tesla
couldn't do that they could do it across
model ex and model s because they they
in fact will use the same battery pack
and we have demonstrated now I mean I
say this there's no way partially you
know my job has been to develop the plug
and socket between the battery and the
in the car right and that is something
you can just push together you shove a
battery pack in there it's connected you
don't have to most almost every other
electric vehicle on the planet that's
ever been built has a cables going into
the battery pack and some sort of bolted
joint somebody's got to get in there
with a wrench and hook those things
together the Model S is the first car I
believe that actually just uses a plug
and socket similar to what your you know
your laptop charger uses it's big it's
about this big around it's got two big
blades that are you know an inch wide
and 1/8 of an inch thick
so that part you can do you can do the
quick connection for the PI power the
low power signal because I did both of
those and it's demonstrate as possible
for the fluid connection that's also we
call them rapid mate connectors for a
fluid end and power and we have
demonstrated a quick swap of a Model S
battery pack with four guys nothing
really automated for guys with with
wrenches and they can swap a pack in
under 10 minutes they it doesn't even
look like they're working that hard when
they do it and most of the time is spent
doing all the bolts on the bottom side
it's you know there's 30 odd bolts that
they have to take out and then they drop
this whole big pack out on a cart
rolling another one shove it up there
they do a little alignment to get it
right there and then slam it home and
bolt it in place and they can do it
pretty quick but the piece that I don't
I can't wrap my head around is how do
you get the companies to organize around
a form factor yes ma'am
if their pitch and they were saying you
know what if we had four different types
of batteries yeah yeah so you could I
they might be right
I very well could be wrong it happens
daily so I'm sure that huh
I could be wrong about this one yeah
that's a North American plant how about
the global long-term plan I haven't seen
maps for that I don't know what the plan
is there isn't there any interest oh I'm
sure there will be we haven't started
selling for instance the Model S is not
for sale yet in Europe and it won't be
until I finished designing the plug that
goes on the outside of the car for the
charger to go in they use they use
three-phase for all their high power
loads in Europe so it's a different form
factor for the plug and I can finish the
design actually right somewhere that I
puke ins so I've called battery packs in
the batteries can be leased instead of
God yes that would be right that would
be a big deal to I would I think that
would offset a lot of the initial cost
of the vehicle so yeah some of you
figure that out but I got a way to
figure that out
go ahead looking at all into like people
do great stuff is that not oh we have a
couple of guys who have been looking at
that stuff I I don't know what the
status of that work is does seem like
there's a lot of potential there and
this could be like one of those things
where there isn't an awesome grid
storage system out there yet because
it's just too expensive so far but oh
look people are putting these big
battery packs in cars and they're
willing to pay the big bucks for them
so yes the the grid storage this this
could be how you make that all work but
but of course
all these things are you know there's
electronic communication one of the one
of the things that comes with the
electric vehicle is you have a
communication to the battery you can
talk to it you can ask it how often it
gets used how much it gets used what its
current state of charge is whether it
likes chocolate or vanilla anything it
knows all that stuff and in fact the
Tesla vehicles if you enable it
Tesla knows all the stuff about your
battery pack too because we have
communications with all those things
wirelessly so you really could say gosh
2 to 4 o'clock is peak use everybody
send your power the other way for a
couple hours and the battery packs could
certainly handle the cycling one of the
I think there's there's challenges of
knowing you know obviously the owner of
the vehicle has to enable that and put
some minimum amount of charge they want
their battery when they come out of
their office at the end of the day to
get home and so there's a bunch of
issues around that but I think they
could take the cycling and as long as
you are careful about that cycling you
get a lot of life out of those battery
packs so I've heard stories about you
know the number of the cycle life of
these packs of this particular cell type
really about if you treat them well like
you only charge them to like 60 or 70%
full you don't actually charge them all
the way to max all the time you don't
take them down to the bottom all the
time they actually will take tens of
thousands of charge cycles it's really
it's really this top to bottom cycling
that just is beats the heck out of them
yes sir sorry what's the end delays plan
so mostly recycling it's an aluminum
closure the the battery the cells
themselves are actually recyclable and
you can recycle them at a profit there
they are the the cells are Rojas
compliant
there's no heavy metals or real
hazardous wastes in them they just grind
them up and they can recycle them yes
sir sorry back to the remove remove
battery question so it can be done with
the Roadster but wouldn't it be feasible
for future models to to design it in
such a way so that it's easier to
exchange batteries yeah yeah you
certainly could do it with the Model S
and and I'm I wouldn't say I'm not
saying it couldn't technically be done
I think there's I think you really could
right now we've got like 30 fasteners to
hold the thing in but obviously if you
design another system for attaching the
pack which it's not a high priority is
no place to swap those packs out it's
not in our business model the the
leasing thing would be an obvious thing
to do but then you're you know what do
you buy and what's the state yeah all I
think that the challenges around the
business of making that work are just
not something that Tesla is ready to get
into yet could be for all I know they'll
announce next week that they're in that
business but I I don't imagine that
being the case we've got so many other
issues to deal with the other question
we're like bringing down the cost of
solar installation by just one we pay
for the energy into the paint for the
solar panels in the first place
it's tests that kind of set up like
going to many where they would help the
customers find them so that there's like
a wide range of adoption and not only
just high-end customers not that I've
heard of
I could certainly imagine that sort of
thing happening in the future but it's
not where we're at yet I think there
they'd still like to turn a profit first
oh and yeah we're not running in the red
yet so I mean we're not running in the
black yet scuse me so yeah we got a ways
to go topic so to Tesla burn through a
lot of cash with the Roadster and with
the big going public and the deal
infusion is there zero projected
timeframe where you're going to be in
the black or or if not how long do you
think other yeah there is definitely a
projected time for when we will be
running in the black I honestly don't
know what that is because I didn't think
to look it up and if I the only data
that I would ever be able to give you
would be stuff that would be readily
available online anyway so if I knew
anything different I couldn't tell you
and I don't so I can't tell you anything
different but yeah it's I think at some
point when you know our goal is to hit a
production rate of about 20,000 vehicles
per year Model S and that's and it's
some point in there we must we must
start running in the black I don't at
some point below 20,000 vehicles per
year we must start running in the black
I'm sure they just released a release of
press release about that at the
quarterly earnings
I think I think it was 200 a week just
10,000 I think that was the number there
was a we had a goal we were trying to
hit some threshold and I kind of think
it was 200 a week I honestly don't
remember if you I'd have to look at the
press release anything else yes sir yeah
you can defer this one your business
people as you'd like to is looking at
sales of electric vehicles and plugins
and if you know you're talking under
10,000 this year we haven't made a dent
in the tons of carbon atmosphere yet
what is it gonna take to really make all
this stuff take off is it the battery
issue that you talked about earlier
isn't very technology better it cost how
do we get to where there's hundreds of
thousands a year of its produced not
just a Tesla but I mean industry so I'm
definitely not the business guy to ask
that question my my personal engineering
perspective is it's all about the cost
you know to me there's there's cost
first volume second you know
lugging around whatever it is a thousand
or 500 kilos of battery payload is is
too much and paying twenty or thirty
thousand dollars for a battery pack is
too much so until those numbers really
come down I wouldn't imagine we'll see
you there really big that would but
that's pure personal speculation
let's take hers
you